bonsoir à tous
vous voyez bien je ne suis pas jean
louis borloo je dirige la fondation
qu'il a créée pour organiser un plan
massif d'accélération de
l'électrification et de la mise à niveau
en termes énergétiques du continent
africain
j'étais avec lui n'djamena la semaine
dernière et n'djamena il faisait entre
40 et 45 degrés donc bon je pense que la
majorité sont français dans la salle moi
aussi comme tout bon français on était
on n'est jamais content user trop chaud
fallait pas olala qu'est ce qu'on allait
faire
on avait la chance d'être dans un hôtel
qui était climatisé on sortait en
voiture climatisée
mais je vous assure que quand vous
sortez dans la rue dans une voiture
climatisée que vous voyez des hommes des
femmes des enfants porter de l'eau
transporter du bois à 45 degrés au
soleil franchement ça calme et ça permet
de relativiser dans l'avion du retour à
l'arrivée vers paris le pilote no
annonce 10 degrés du brouillard
et là la discussion reprend ah oui mais
moi j'aime bien quand il pleut et qui
fait pas humide moi j'aime pas
l'humidité moi j'aime pas la pluie
tout ça est bien dérisoire ce matin
j'arrive à la gare de lille
d'après vous quel est le premier sujet
de conversation que j'ai abordé avec la
première personne que j'ai rencontrée à
l'huile le temps voilà c'est bien
dérisoire
regardez cette carte cette carte c'est
l'afrique l'afrique
entourée d'un halo de lumière l'afrique
ce continent qui a plus de 300 jours
d'ensoleillement par an et qui est
plongé dans le noir dans 30 ans un quart
des actifs de la planète seront
africains
il faudra les nourrir les loger les
éduquer leur trouver un travail
les soigner et la moitié de cette
population aura moins de 25 ans mais le
chiffre le plus hallucinant qui me
surprend toujours
c'est uniquement un africain sur quatre
a accès à l'énergie
un africain sur quatre dans un continent
ensoleillé quasiment toute l'année ça
c'est ce que vivent les africains au
quotidien quand ils ont la chance
d'avoir de l'électricité
ça s'appelle le délestage permanent si
je vous dis ça c'est parce que l'accès à
l'énergie
bien sûr que c'est l'accès à un besoin
fondamental un droit fondamental
mais pour nous c'est avant tout un plan
de paix et de stabilité pour l'europe
l'afrique qui se développe pour nous est
notre plus grande chance et notre plus
grand enjeu la croissance de l'afrique
et la croissance de l'europe sont
intimement liés bien sûr que l'accès à
l'énergie c'est l'axé un droit
fondamental
un droit essentiel c'est un nouveau
droit de l'homme c'est un droit
fondamental
quand on n'a pas accès à l'énergie on
peut pas faire grand chose
tout est lié aujourd'hui l'énergie ce
n'est pas une question technique
ce n'est pas une question d'ingénieurs
c'est un vrai sujet politique majeur
c'est la mère de tous les développements
lénine disait que le socialisme ce sont
les soviets plus l'électricité
c'était vrai au 20e siècle c'est encore
plus vrai aujourd'hui on ne peut rien
faire sans énergie je disais tout à
l'heure alors on est face à des enjeux
considérables
le premier enjeu c'est un enjeu
sanitaire l'alimentation la
transformation des aliments
la conservation de la chaîne du froid si
on a pas d'énergie on ne peut pas le
faire vous savez que la première cause
de mortalité infantile
c'est l'absence d'eau potable encore
aujourd'hui en afrique
ensuite dans les hôpitaux on ne peut pas
avoir une médecine durable et constante
si on a pas d'énergie encore la semaine
dernière à djamena quelqu'un nous
racontait que sa belle-soeur est décédé
pendant une césarienne parce qu'il ya
une coupure d'électricité
ça arrive encore aujourd'hui ensuite
c'est un enjeu éducatif les enfants pour
faire leurs devoirs après l'école ont
besoin d'énergie
les enseignants pour accepter accéder à
cette vaste connaissance ces bases de
données bibliothécaire d'information ou
wikipedia les mook toute cette modernité
tout ce qui enrichit l'enseignement
aujourd'hui mais ce n'est pas possible
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'énergie
ensuite c'est un enjeu important pour la
condition des femmes en afrique ce sont
les femmes qui vont chercher de l'eau ce
sont les femmes qui vont chercher du
bois
et quand je dis les femmes bien souvent
ce sont les petites filles parce que ça
commence tout petit je suis originaire
du bénin est un village qui s'appelle
covè ou années ma mère ma mère
accompagnait sa mère qui elle même
accompagnée à sa grand mère moi je suis
extrêmement privilégiée je suis né en
ville je n'ai pas connu ça j'ai une vie
facile en vie le tout le monde
la condition des femmes c'est un enjeu
important
ça leur laisserait beaucoup de temps
pour s'occuper de leur famille
c'est un enjeu territorial également on
se retrouve avec des véritable chaudron
urbain quand vous imaginez que tous les
jeunes quittent la campagne pour aller
vers la ville parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'emploi parce qu'ils n'ont pas accès à
l'énergie et maintenant ce qui est quand
même extraordinaire c'est qu'on voit
bien que les jeunes en afrique voit ce
qui se passe partout en europe
ils ont accès à l'information par
internet par les téléphones portables
on voit bien que maintenant le phénomène
migratoire
il est lié au fait que dans leur
territoire ils ne peuvent plus implanté
plus de 200 mille migrants ont traversé
la méditerranée en 2016 c'est énorme
un enjeu territorial aussi pour un
meilleur équilibre du territoire
si nous avions de l'électricité on
pourrait développer des métiers de
proximité développer des emplois pour
que les jeunes puissent rester sur leur
territoire et c'est un enjeu de justice
climat l'afrique est le continent qui
émet le moins de co2 et c'est pourtant
le continent qui est le plus impacté par
les dérèglements climatiques provoqués
par les états développés et ça il va
bien falloir que quelqu'un paye un jour
aujourd'hui il ya la déforestation il ya
des sécheresse accrue et a énormément de
des règlements qui sont liées à la
mauvaise utilisation des ressources nous
si nous avons lancé avec jean louis
borloo cette grande opération c'est
parce que nous croyons profondément que
quand l'afrique s'illuminera elle
rallumera la croissance de l'europe et
du monde
énergie pour l'afrique c'est un
plaidoyer depuis deux ans pour mobiliser
l'opinion publique internationale
les conditions sont réunies aujourd'hui
pour que ça réussisse
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
africains ont délibéré à plusieurs
reprises encore la semaine dernière le
sommet des chefs d'état d'afrique de
l'ouest à la cedeao
a délibéré et adopté à l'unanimité la
création d'un fonds spécial de soutien
qui va venir financer des projets
d'électrification
donc on voit bien que le phénomène est
en marche il faut maintenant que les
états occidentaux fassent leur part du
chemin et participe globalement à ce
projet qui je vous lis encore une fois
est un vaste projet de paix et de
stabilité pour le continent et puis tout
ça arrive à un moment où nous vivons une
époque extraordinaire avec l'avènement
des nouvelles technologies avec internet
la troisième révolution industrielle
avec l'essor d'internet c'est une chance
extraordinaire pour l'afrique c'est une
chance extraordinaire pour rapprocher ce
continent qui a seulement 14 km de nos
côtes de notre vie quotidienne de nous
connecter ensemble nos destins sont
étroitement liés l'afrique est le
continent qui a subi le choc
démographique d'une magnitude sans
précédent en 1950 l'afrique comptait 180
millions d'habitants en 2050 l'afrique
comptera 2 milliard d'habitants
ça n'existe pas dans l'histoire de
l'humanité vous imaginez si la france si
l'europe avait subi un choc de cette
magnitude
on n'arrive déjà pas à nourrir à loger
les gens à 5 millions de chômeurs
comment on ferait et moi je suis très
optimiste
je suis très optimiste parce que je me
dis quand même un continent qui a
seulement 25% d'accès à l'énergie et qui
affiche 4 % de taux de croissance bas
alors qu'est ce que ça serait s'il
affichait 10 % taux de croissance jean
tirole qui est prix nobel d'économie a
fait une étude avec nous et lui il pense
que si l'afrique affiche 10 % de taux de
croissance et 2 % de taux de croissance
supplémentaire pour l'europe c'est
formidable ce extraordinaire ça nous
lieraient pour toujours nous sommes
cousins un petit peu en a et d histoire
commune
alors moi de quoi on a besoin
aujourd'hui on n'a pas besoin d'argent
moi ce que je souhaiterais mon rêve mon
rêve
c'est que ce projet devienne réalité
c'est qu'on passe de 25% à 100%
d'électrification de l'afrique l'afrique
est pleine de ressources naturelles il
ya de l'eau il ya du vent il ya du
soleil c'est possible c'est faisable en
dix ans pour ça on a besoin de vous
on a besoin d'un vaste mouvement
populaire on a besoin que vous rejoignez
cette alliance pour la lumière c'est
inéluctable il faut que ça devienne
irréversible
si vous voulez nous aider vous allez sur
nrj pour l'afrique point org vous
cliquez juste un clic ou vous nous
faites un selphy que vous nous envoyez
ça sera votre contribution au progrès de
l'humanité
aidez moi à réaliser mon rêve je vous
remercie